alright well it's not as our next
speaker as sovsem is a corner organizer
of the workshop I'm he lemmerman up
towards capturing order independently
okay but thank you no chance i'm really
delighted to be here and this is for me
this has kind of been the semester from
hell so I just want to apologize what
I'm teaching I was explaining it so a
bunch of people there I'm teaching 155
UMass sophomores how what mathematics is
what a proof is what a definition is
what a lemma is what induction is what
ordering is what close relation is what
a graph is and so on and making them
prove things about it and you know in my
spare time I'm trying to do other things
so it feels like a wonderful vacation to
be here and I want you to give a talk
about something that many of you by now
in the in the here have already
surpassed and and there's a lot of
understanding of this budget this is
there's a problem I want to talk about
that I think is really really basic
really important really interesting and
there's been so much new development
about us i'm going to tell you a little
bit about it and um sue Martin I'm gonna
talk some about the Oh perhaps you can
prove this life you're in momentum
theorem from so many years ago Martin
Fury's here genius I said maybe I'll
come and then there's my last email from
him so so I don't see him today but
maybe he'll be here tomorrow on and of
course i'll be talking about um choices
problems time and andres blast and your
gravy to hear so so it's it's great um
so I I just this that I have a lot of
slides and I'll just skip through them
if this works um just to to talk about
where where I'm coming from which is
descriptive complexity at which I'll
remind you know some people just
basically it's a way of viewing come
from Mike reviewing computational
complexity from a from a completely
logical point of view so in complexity
where is talking about decision problems
does this input have a certain property
in descriptive complexity we're saying
well how hard is it to express that
property in some kind of form of
language
and instead of saying how much time or
space or processors blah blah blah do
you need to check if the input has a
certain property I want to say how which
language don't need to express the
property so the property is the property
of the input so the input is a finite
structure and so we're doing logic of
our finance structures which on most
logicians will tell you it's just
trivial and you know it's not trivial
it's different and it's much more like
comet Oryx and you can what I've found
over the years is that anytime anybody
you I hear a question about computer
science I can translate it to this
language and then I can sort of
understand what it says so so there is
and that can be done automatically
although although it's hard for most
people to do but this is just another
approach to computation which works for
logic and so the you know many of you
seen this many times before sir my
favorite diagram of what the world looks
like and does everyone know my story
about Daniel and the cover my book not
everyone ok ok so I finally after many
years road to monograph about about this
stuff and it was in the Springer series
of whatever series it was there all the
covers of her grey and the editors who
are at Cornell answer my question said
ok you can put a diagram on the cover so
I came home I was really pleased and I
said I was Daniel who is like my son 10
years old then once it was about I said
well this diagram sort of explains a lot
of a lot of what's going on in the book
and Daniel attorney said that's very
good daddy that means no one will buy
that book who shouldn't
anyway let me take two words of this
diagram that could I could I could just
leave the diagram here forever and so
basically um so in some sense um they're
all these complexity clouds like this is
none in terms of polynomial time which
this whole field of description
collected started with Ron Fagan who was
thinking of coming when we invited him
because he's not yet not going to come
from and so Ron proved in his PhD thesis
Oh glue that NP is equal to second or
existential so completely a completely
logical characterization of NP and I
thought I was a um I heard about this
couple years later when I was a grad
student and I thought wow you know no
one's going to be able to prove that
Turing machines can't do a certain
number of things like this but logic we
have all these tools so i was excited
about that and also thought oh I'm never
going to prove something's not second or
expressible that's too powerful so I
looked at building up from first order
logic and originally I thought the first
order was really in some sense too weak
too weak to be interesting so your input
of course Howard just talked about this
you're in first order includes regular
properties it's not too weak to be
interesting but it's pretty weak as a
complexity class on and it turns out
later a kind of the first story
corresponds to constant parallel time
when you have partnered with many
processors and concurrent mall so
exactly it's actually a very nice model
and coming up here we found out that
increasing the number the basically the
iteration depth of a formula or
inductive definition is exactly parallel
time and what's very nice well I can't
talk for the whole time got the starter
but anyway so we have all these
characterizations and all of these
depend upon on in ordering on the
universe so so I of course being
logicians you're all familiar with
inductive definitions and from UM from
my point of view inductive definition
the the most standard one is I have a
graph I want to
cribe say e star which is the reflexive
transitive closure of E and of course
that's not first-order expressible we
can define it by inductive definition so
my Denton deputy definitions are
typically on positive so so then the
relation being defined only appears
positively so in that case we have at
our screen aster theorem which is pretty
obvious in the in the finite case that
says it says that a polynomial number of
iterations you'll reach early six-point
so we have a least fixed point operator
which can which which formula is making
inductive definitions so so from this on
we get on the theorem that says
polynomial time is is equal to exactly
first order logic plus inductive
definitions and another way of thinking
that is the least Victoria operator in
this setting is just a polynomial
iterator it's taking a sort of a fixed
block of restricted crime fighters and
iterating it Apollo me many times and
this way off and think of it so so just
you know you know you whatever that
means you you you take a fix blocks
apart your search providers iterate it
with the same variable so it's a binary
number variables polynomial much and
that's problem your time and that
depends on the fact that our input
structure is ordered so mostly what I
talked about today is this ordering
issue which i think is really
fascinating and and very relevant to
this symmetry workshop and on and by the
way graphs is I I tell even my you know
my my sophomores in discrete math
everything is the graph that's the only
thing you have to look at you can
understand everything as a graph so we
don't have to go beyond graphs and it's
a theorem in first order logic
everything is a graph ok so um so we
just talked about graphs from now on and
on
and as I said the above theorem requires
ordering in some sense our input is a
graph but from a from a pure
mathematical point of view of what's a
graph the set of vertices with an edge
relation on it can be directed or
undirected arm but from a computational
point of view I want to input that graph
so I need vertex one vertex two up to
vertex and they have to be ordered that
watering has nothing to do with the
properties of the graph so sorry I don't
want an algorithm to take that graph and
use the ordering and do something
special because of the ordering ok so
I'd like to know I have my algorithm I'd
like to know if it's order independent
that's of course undecidable as any
question about turning machines is
undecidable like that but on which
really what we care about order
independent why don't you just input a
graph without an ordering that's
impossible ok and I just I mean I
thought about this for years and it's
really funny what even is a graph this
mathematical concept a graph a set of
vertices that's unordered you can't show
it to me throw it on the board that's an
ordering give it any labels you know any
language you know if that's an ordering
so you can't even talk about it's not
just the computer's fault you can't talk
about in a specific way a graph without
an ordering as far as I know and I'm
sure someone will contradict me an
example of a way that you maybe you
could but a finite graph that's not
ordered how do you exactly say what it
is you know which vertex has the edge to
which other vertex if you can't name
them in a way that sort of gives an
ordering ok so this is kind of
fundamental problem any any input to a
computer as you know is justice it's
just a binary string so it comes in
ordering and all the things you can do
in polynomial time or all the things you
can express in Luke's fix point but now
here we're really interested in this
issue of is that algorithm order
independent can you is there any way to
recursively list out all of the order
independent polynomial time properties
of graphs it's easy to introduce all the
polynomial time properties of autographs
you know the things we usually get
because you just put a clock on it on
the computer
stop you know just I'll say okay this is
an algorithm that runs in N squared I
can prove that because after an scratch
steps it stops and says no okay so you
can list out all the pollen term
properties of water graphs can you list
out all the pollen time properties of
graphs of order and that's completely
open and this is sort of the question
okay and I've conjectured yes eurisk
rejected know and and that was many
years ago and we still don't know okay
so this is the question I'm really
really interested in and as I say
ordering is really necessary okay and of
course for graphs the ordering is
irrelevant right so the program is wrong
in some sense of it depends on the order
okay and I'd like to know that so what
what we would like to do is a theorem
like this so called a minbari theorem
but for unordered graphs so is there
some way to capture what I'm calling
here order independent pay so oip in
this talk is this order independent pay
their interests and when it is all the
polynomial time properties of graphs
that are order independent a question
there's none of questions you will try
okay and um and just pointing out so
when you first look at this okay for
serologic with all this text point is P
question click here instead of oil feed
should be just be
exactly he's not mean I agree I agree I
agree but it's not exactly yes yes I'm
just trying to capture p but then people
say oh that's already been done you know
doing this so I call it okay but I know
I tell you agree I'm just trying to
capture pit that's right and I'm going
to tell anybody we haven't done it yet
though so and just but if you take this
language you just remove the ordering
it's just too weak first order with
these fixed point and no ordering on
graphs for normal graphs it's okay you
can walk on the edges but for an empty
graph with no edges it's kind of a
hardly week language because because any
fixed formula in lips fixed point as I
said it's just one fix formulas a fixed
number of variables iterated butts only
has a fixed number of variables so can
only talk about k objects at a time so
even something as simple as saying does
my graph have an even number of vertices
or if you know how to count the number
of the universe does it have an even
number of edges those are not in this
language okay and and that by the way is
um um so even as an example of something
in order independent pay but not this
candidate language without the ordering
okay so so that certainly is our first
trial first order without ordering and
fixed point is not is not strong enough
and question so sorry this is no no Cup
matters oh why do I mean why why should
polynomial time be important oh yeah why
we cared why would we care all
interesting um um um
so oh yeah okay great that's what this
talk is about so let me see if I can try
to express it um so for me I mean it's
so DC this is going to take a bitter to
defer to get it out but i can tell you
on on one of the issues is really i want
to know on well one thing i wanted to do
when I was a kid you know like a good
student I was trying to improve p naught
equal to NP no one knew at that time it
was so hard and and and to do that I was
kind of using Aaron foot per se games
with the problems there in fort pierce a
games is that the in substance they lose
all their activity once you have an
ordering because you can just say this
is vertex 17 this is vertex 3 and
there's an edge there or not so you
can't distinguish different graphs with
ordering so so my goal was really to
play Eric's a games without the ordering
but in a context that it was strong
enough to to capture polynomial time and
then I could prove use meta cooler MP so
that was my original goal and then
there's a whole database community who
who had a sort of theology that the
algorithm should be independent of how
the data is actually stored on the disk
and that means order independent so it's
a lot of interest from the database
community for order independence so that
so we got it going for me it was always
this basic question but the other
question is just um so now i want to i
would like I have the structure I would
like to capture its essence without
ordering and and seems like a question
logicians would like to know the the
polynomial time is an afterthought which
I'm really interested in but just even
just that question let's capture the
essence of the structure without the
ordering yeah in defense of that
theology i'm cherdon lack of order
independence allows optimizations that
make queries you run faster okay okay so
on so no no audience is great it's the
god of a fish
see that that feel I never thought of it
that way okay okay okay okay great so
there's two reasons at least okay so
this is the absolute question I want to
do I want to say okay how do we
characterize properties of graphs that
that our order independent how we list
out all the order independent polymer 10
properties of drafts okay I think it's
really interesting i'll talk about it
more see if you're good okay so um and I
just want to mention how do you approve
even is not in first order without
ordering these fixed point I sketched
that um you know with airport per se
games so everybody knows that earn per
person again sir yeah okay so they
they're fun and for some reason i called
it I call the players Sampson delilah
instead of spoiler and duplicator but on
if you haven't played them before you
can soon being played right now and uh
and the key thing about the games is
that on let me say this notation G till
the super case of MH means that Delilah
the duplicator has has a winning
strategy for the game on on that goes
for EM moves and has k pebbles so
pebbles correspond to variables and so
if Delilah has a winning strategy for
the am ok pebble game I say G tilde
caves super km/h and the fundamental
theorem of these games is that Delilah
has this winning strategy on the K
pebble and move game if and only if G
and H agree on exactly all four sort of
formulas with at most K variables to
language L superkick k variables in
quantified F M so movement the game is
exactly a one more nesting of quantifier
depth number of fingers you have on the
board pebbles is the same as number of
variables okay so so from that it's
obvious that you can't say even to say
even I need a linear number I need a
variable for every single vertex
otherwise I can't distinguish these two
make sense everyone great okay so and
again to answer this person's question
against what was your name all right sit
tight okay so sit hearts question on I
really want to be able to play in four
games pretty silly games in effect
way that has something to about
computation but doesn't use the ordering
that messes me up okay that's that's
that's really what I want and so one
thing so so since just hanging out
wearing wasn't working the counter
examples were were all in terms of
counting things even number of edges you
know majority of the bits are on things
like that so I thought okay let's just
add counting quantifiers so we're going
to think of our logic now the the graph
is just n vertices but there's no
ordering on diversities but I have it oh
it's a two-story structure so I have
numbers to let's say numbers from 0 to n
on and and on the numbers there's the
usual arithmetic I have ordering plus
relations times relations what have you
and on and then I want to be able to
count I want to accounting quantify or
maybe let's say there's three vertices
where the five vertices steps in
something and more modern treatments do
to Martin gaara and others instead of
counting quantifiers they just use
accounting accounting term so number X
such that Phi of X means exactly means
that number the number the number of X
is such the 5x okay so I'll use that
notation in this talk okay so I what I
want to have is um yeah yeah they I did
to myself tick oh so now Oh
oh oh I just pulled it out great I'm
sorry so let me talk for me at while
that comes up again great so says okay I
can now count and and i still only tell
you about our infinite properties
because my graph is not ordered but at
least I up counting now and now i can
say even for example is easy i just say
there exists a number i which is even
and where the number of x is set to x
equals x equals 2 I so the number of
number of vertices is even clearer okay
so I've counting and let me define see
Super K to be our first order logic
within most k k vertex variables X 1 to
X K but I can count okay and umm so so
counting means I've counted qualifiers
or for this talk just these counting
terms and then we can talk about FPC
which is first our logic with a fixed
point operator and counting okay and the
reason I'm talking about see Super K is
that each formula in this language which
has a fixed point operator so it
iterates formulas and they have counting
has a fixed number of variables so it's
in so this is so every particular
formula in here is in CKD for some k and
i'll play errand for Cosette games with
the ck and I have like whiteness okay so
let's let me just move a little bit um
there's there were various standard
graph isomorphism algorithms that people
were looking at starting with um for
example on vertex coloring so about that
calls this the vice fellow layman method
so you can color vertices by how many
how many are what their degree is and
then so for example these blue ones are
of degree for everyone else's of degree
3 and now at the next round that's the
point of our depth 1
goes at the next round this one has one
neighbor one blue neighbor and one black
neighbor this one has two black
neighbors so the next round they get
different colors and if you can see them
these are blue these are is a magenta
okay and so on and then if you do stable
coloring that's just computing the
c-type and each round of this table
coloring is is a step of the c-type now
very interesting on by by eros and sell
cash a long time ago that with high
probability take a random graph and and
you color it just vertex color it four
steps every vertex has a unique name
okay which means you've you put that
graph into a canonical form because
because those those names by the way or
alphabetically ordered so now you have
an ordered graph and each ordering has a
specific meaning having to do with the
graph so what that means is that graph
canonization for almost all graphs can
be done in linear time very simple
algorithm okay so is this there is this
algorithm and so graph isomorphism is
very easy for random graphs however
general graphs graph isomorphism is
unknown and of course last year there is
this you know Bob I armed with wonderful
deep difficult to understand for me at
least group theoretical algorithms moved
the graph isomorphism upper bound from n
to the square root of n down to end to
the poly log on and on and his estimate
right now it's into the locks in 7-10
but ensure that number that seven won't
go down but he and several other people
were organizing a Dodge stalled workshop
the first ever last December on graph
isomorphism and maybe for that reason
Bob I wrote his thesis on Gotham were
chosen maybe that reason he worked a
little harder and he got this result
which he gets it presented the seminar
and and I had the pleasure to be there
and that's part of why I'm sorry looking
at this now I think we're ready to solve
some of these problems in my opinion nah
not me
you ready um so anyway Oh three minutes
put it over yeah 3 minutes okay okay so
um um so c2 and c3 you know there's nice
polynomial time algorithms to check just
using these ever per se games whether
two graphs rc2 equivalent so almost all
graphs rc2 equivalent about almost all
graphs they see two equivalent only if
there are some more pic okay and it
doesn't work so well c 2 doesn't work
for regular graphs but c 3 does from us
all regular graphs there c 3 equivalent
in a short number of steps only if
they're isomorphic okay and you can't
SDK equivalents in polynomial time so a
whole bunch of Russian computer
scientists the group started by Vice
whoa a layman we're trying to work and
see well maybe there's some constant
like three such that arm such that C
three equivalents in other words
labeling pairs was enough to do graph
isomorphism maybe maybe it was known for
three and it was open for four okay so
late lowing triples well the seafloor
equivalence wasn't up for grabs a
morphism in which case gratify some more
person would be in polynomial time and
we'd have a polymer time canonical
algorithm canonical form paragraphs in
which case oh I p and p are the same
because you can just take the graph
canonize it and then run your algorithm
so it's automatically owner independent
so if if graph has more fizz or craft
canonization turns out to be in
polynomial time then P&O IP just the
same thing problem is solved doesn't
necessarily help me prove pinochle NP
but still it's a nice solution that
makes sense a row that's still that
could be true okay we still have no idea
where the graph isomorphism is isn't
pure now at least I have no idea and I
don't think too many people have a
strong strong idea um I'm so hoping that
the right bound is into the log in and
it's but anyway um so anyway um so that
was it um so is an open question it was
fixed point on with counting equal to
order independent pay there's an open
quite a while ago and the paper with
with Martin periods and news I we showed
a lot
that's the so-called nemesis I purim
rumen problem is not is not piling the
time so is um so basically it was open
whether seaport characterize all graphs
and when we showed is no you need you
need a linear number of vertices on two
characters I'll graphs and it's me just
show you the picture okay that's that's
on that's sort of a nice little core
gadget that has a bunch of of
automorphisms this is a graph on the red
versus on top the green ones in the left
side in the blue on right side and the
middle ones are maybe black or magenta
so this is a graph of color class size
for so in some sense I can't so we're
going back to distinguish between these
four points otherwise I have a graph
that's going to be it's going to be
ordered up to color class size four so
it's almost ordered but not quite and
and what we showed is ok on you can you
can put that gadget together in a graph
that has high separator sighs and then
maybe flip one of these edges in the
suits graphs this is a huge graph of
color class size for so it's almost
ordered except some for tuples I can't
tell the difference and yet you can't
tell the difference you can't tell is
there an even or odd number of flips ok
so you can't do isomorphism on those
simple graphs even though it's a linear
time very simple property if you if the
grass were ordered you could see whether
or not the edges were flipped so so this
was an exists called size for an example
and it's fun to play there in force a
game which if we had another hour we
could do and so we showed ok this simple
property now called the superior every
property on is linear time it's very
simple but it distinguishes it's not
expressible in fixed point with counting
but then there was all this fantastic
work anusha has a wonderful survey paper
in sig log newsletter from a year ago
something about the amazing power of FPC
you know after this lower bound i sort
of forgot i love that language but I
said oh it didn't work but there's FEC
is actually
very very powerful and really
interesting and um so for example Oh
Martin grohe you know the long series of
work he showed he showed the planar
graphs there was a fixed number of
variables I don't know what it is seven
variables that that characterizes planar
graphs so two graphs are Aquila rc7
equivalents there are some Orphic and
then he he and his students proved a few
more things and finally they proved that
for huge classes of graphs any class of
graphs that's um that's on that excludes
them a minor is characterized by sea que
pour some K so so if this point with
counting is very very good it captures
it captures pong amoooo IP on any such
class of graphs any graph with a bounded
genus any graph with it um I think about
a degree and any graph with bounded tree
size and so on so quite it quite amazing
nap down degrees no no see if I is over
oh sorry don't see if I his manners are
good thank you the inertia see I'd say
I'm just okay thank you very much for
keeping me honest I appreciate um so not
down a degree even though banner degree
of chris is pounding your time so it's
so that's that and that raises an
interesting question with generation
students and postdocs have been working
on on you know what do we have to add
now for me with the ad or what other
language would you can you take pics
point FPC and add to that to get this
problem and all the other problems
they're just squeaking out and and I
mean so so Yuri and um and Andreas is
choices polynomial time language arm
been rossman Indonesian one other person
proved that that that was strong enough
to cap just express this property and a
news and others introduced rank logic
where what will add is have a sort of
unordered matrix and take its rank as a
new operation and that's a fixed point
plus counting you get this property
but to those to capture order
independent p maybe we don't know and
you guys should figure it out okay okay
you must have a question coming I think
just once okay okay break break for
lifestyle okay